un peu seul ces parents d'élèves de
trappe mardi devant l'inspection
académique le mouvement de contestation
s'essouffle contre la mise en place des
la rentrée 2013 de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires ils étaient venus
faire part de leurs inquiétudes ils ont
été reçus près d'une heure et dem en
gros les deux éléments principaux
portent sur le début de la classe alors
faut-il commencer à 8h30 faut-il
commencer à 8h50 faut-il commencer à 9h
on a à peu près toutes les tèes
possibles et imaginables de chose c'est
que les activités périscolaires ne sont
pas encore définies comme elles sont pas
définies évidemment ça crée des
inquiétudes que va-il se passer est-ce
que ce sera vraiment des activités
périscolaires est-ce que ça sera de la
garderie à quel moment dans quelles
conditions à quelle heure faudra-il
amener les enfants toutes ces questions
là ne sont pas réglé le directeur
académique adjoint va contacter
prochainement le maire de trappe où 36
écoles sont concerné ce qui en fait la
plus importante des h villes des
ivelines a opté pour la semaine de 4
jours dès
septembre